so construction was great and then i got
a better offer
to smuggle drugs across the tijuana
board wow allegedly you got allegedly
yeah i mean whatever dude says you are a
mule yeah i was a meal well you had
drugs um hash
okay yeah so hash huh over the mexican
border yeah from mexico to us or us to
mexico so the old the old dude uncle
danny i don't think a lot of people are
smuggling drugs into mexico okay fair
enough
he's up in heaven now okay uncle danny
dude he was this old-timer that lived at
the surf shop and he was a porto
escondido local like when we go to porto
you get you know so what was your method
scott loves asking uh like rock stars
how they would smuggle drugs or what was
your method oh dude i got the best
method ever it worked so good keister no
no no i would not have your butthole
so yeah how do you smuggle so this old
guy was at the surf shop you know he
would visit the surf shop and i'm like
he's in and out so but he's super cool
we weren't even 21 yet we'd like hey can
you buy some beers you'd be like yeah
for sure but we'd always be like a
dollar short you'd get so pissed but um
so he passed away
and they asked me they go poopies you
want to take over uncle danny's job and
i kind of knew what he did
and i was like [ __ ] dude i was like well
what do we got to do he's like well you
got to smuggle hash across the border
and we'll pay you two g's
how much hash
four kilos wow that's more than you can
fit in your butt yeah
is that like ten pounds
two point two pounds per kilo four
yeah that's just about almost it's eight
point eight pound or
yeah something yeah almost 10 pounds
pounds that's a lot that's like uh four
ziploc bags yeah so it was all wrapped
up but um so
as [ __ ] i'll do it you know i i was like
[ __ ] it i'll do it i was dumb as [ __ ]
dude how old were you 18. that's like
life
said that you're okay whatever yeah
eighteen so after construction after
okay so i got fired from that and then i
was like [ __ ] i was kind of in the in
the way so how it deserves 8.8 pounds of
cash so my friend my friend um lives in
laguna beach and um he was kind of part
of the deal too so i was i took over
uncle danny's spot which he's the best
smuggler in the world so they had their
you know they had their ways of doing it
so i met up with this guy
um in a hotel tijuana hotel like the
nice one and i'd go up to his room and
he'd have these pajamas like um
like
john's it would be sewn into the pajamas
yep pockets sewn into the long johns so
i put on the long johns and then he'd
put these bricks of hash on me straight
out of that movie the wolf of wall
street right now midnight express
yeah yeah yeah it was [ __ ] crazy so
my first time i'm like dude what the
[ __ ] am i doing and i can't go the first
time so
so yeah the first time so i was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing but when do you
wear anything over in the long run yeah
so yeah they put all the hash on me and
they tape it all up so you're dressed up
like you're going to [ __ ] ski resort
but it's actually tijuana where it's
like super warm you're the only guy i've
dressed for winter
and this was the thing you got to wear
loose clothing over it
so i look like some [ __ ] weirdo with
loose clothing and
big boobs oh dude so i would they tape
it up on me put on the loose clothing
and they'd like all right well now let's
go get some drinks
so i'd go out and tj and have drinks
with all this strapped on me to get
comfortable with it right right so you
don't want to be too nervous going yeah
yeah so i would just be off wasted you
know like yeah we're partying
dude they don't even know i have [ __ ]
eight pounds of hash on me and then i go
through the borderline with all the
party kids
and they're like what are you doing here
oh i'm just partying you know and
they're like all right grandma are you
thinking like man a dog might smell this
dude
so all they would have to do is just
touch me and they would feel it and dude
they'd have dogs right there too i would
just like kind of just not look at you
there were dogs when you had that much
hat strapped to you yeah the dog didn't
nope
it was it was no smell
they're really good at what they do uh
so they were packing it in like vacuum
sealed bags yeah so they'd bring it from
porto they'd make it in porto in the
oaxaca mountains okay so she got through
without any issues yeah got through
without
two grand for that one walk across the
border
and how many times did you do that i did
that
twice but the second time was so sketch
dude like i thought i was gonna get
busted but luckily i didn't
and i [ __ ] made it through and
i have to have it still on me too when i
have to make it up like
at least past north county with it so
and then finally they cut it off me i
get get to this guy's house they cut it
all off me dude i could [ __ ] breathe
dude because i couldn't breathe dude
with it all on me and [ __ ] and i have to
like suck in and like show them my
passport yo i'm just here partying like
trying to suck it all in dude it was
[ __ ] gnarly damn how much of the two
grand would you spend in tijuana that
night oh i wouldn't get paid until i
made it all the way oh okay yeah i'd go
straight to 7-eleven grab slurpees all
the candy all the hot dogs for all my
boys
we were living large at that surf shop
after a run for real yeah it was gnarly
but yeah dude that was the smuggling
[ __ ] and i was over that dude
so i started going up north to trimweed
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you